le nombre de contaminations toujours
très élevé en france plus de 400 mille
cas de covin recensés hier parce
vaccinale contamination élevée peut-on
croire un retour rapide à la vie normale
et bien on va en parler et tout de suite
avec un autre éditorialiste le
sociologue michel fize
m michel fize bonjour bonjour heureux de
vous retrouver sur le plateau et même de
rt france alors on annonce à la fin
prochaine de l'épidémie comment les
français ils appréhendent ce moment je
pense qu'inconsciemment il ya du
soulagement
chez la plupart d'entre nous mais il ya
aussi sans doute un peu de prudence 1
par rapport à ces annonces
gouvernementales
il faut bien le reconnaître très très
optimiste
et puis je crois quand même qu'il ne
sont pas dû parce que quand on relit ça
effectivement la campagne présidentielle
on s'aperçoit que il ya un enjeu
électoraliste derrière ces derrières ces
annonces parce qu'elle nous amène fin
février début mars et je rappelle que le
4 mars est la date butoir pour présenter
la candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
donc effectivement un président qui
arriverait le 4 mars où un petit peu
avant avec une épidémie quasiment rayée
de la carte française ce serait ce
serait évidemment un un atout voilà
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs la raison qui
explique cet optimisme qui est quand
même un petit peu atténuées par des
chiffres qui restent qui reste haut ce
que je rappelle qu'on a quand même
encore 400 mille cas par jour 2 de
contamination même s'il ya un reflux qui
semble hypothèse évidemment la plus
probable aujourd'hui par michel quand
vous êtes arrivé sur le plateau on sait
pas serrer la main est-ce qu'on va
retrouver ses gestes d'avant les
habitudes qui nous rendait finalement
proches les uns des autres je crois
qu'il faut d'abord rappeler quelques
fondamentaux sains l'homme est un être
sociable il a besoin de contacter un et
il est évident que les bisous les câlins
dont on a été privé bon les amours en
tête mais pas que un petit peu un petit
peu tout le monde bon ça constitue un
manque dans une vie dans une vie normale
et puis vous le disiez la simple poignée
de main c'est convivial une poignée de
main être obligé de fermer la main
chaque fois pour checker bon c'est sûr
que c'est sait moins c - convives à
conviviale alors je crois que d'ailleurs
que beaucoup de gestes sont revenus on
voit bien qu'il ya des bisous ici ou là
des poignées de main et que ça va se
confirmer au fil au fil des semaines je
pense qu'on est arrivé à un niveau de
saturation maintenant la machine est
inversée on veut reprendre
progressivement la vie et la vie normale
si par malheur il ya une nouvelle vague
épidémique qui surgit est ce que les
français il supporterait le retour aux
anciennes contre hearts je ne pense que
le retour aux anciens contraintes qui a
signifié quand même pendant deux ans des
les commandements du pouvoir ça je pense
que ça semble peu
peu probable parce que d'abord les
français ont acquis de l'expérience dans
la gestion de cette de cette crise
sanitaire depuis deux ans donc ils
savent ce qu'il faut faire ou ne pas
faire en telle ou telle circonstance je
vais prendre un exemple tout simple à
paris à paris le port du masque en
extérieur n'est plus obligatoire et bien
moi je suis frappé de voir que beaucoup
de parisiens portent encore le masson là
et je suis de ceux qui considèrent que
dans telle ou telle circonstance il vaut
mieux évidemment le porter
donc je pense que la prochaine étape
s'il y avait ce scénario catastrophe ce
serait de faire davantage confiance aux
français ils n'ont pas besoin qu'on leur
tienne la main pour leur dire si vous
portez un masque dans un magasin qui est
bondé ou au contraire dans un espace à
l'extérieur vide vide de monde je pense
que non mais ça semble peu probable mais
je crois encore une fois que la
démocratie c'est la confiance donc il
faudra davantage agitée dans le cas de
cette hypothèse sur le levier de la
confiance plus que sur le levier du
commandement plus de confiance c'est ce
que demandent aussi un ceux qui défilent
cet après midi contre le vaccinale on
l'a vu il y a un instant est-ce que ce
pass vous avez pu observer qu'il a
encore plus diviser les français
finalement divise encore je pense que on
aurait pu redouter un affrontement entre
vacciner anti vacciner mais je crois que
ni les uns ni les autres ne sont tombés
dans le piège qu'on pouvait lors leur
leur présenter je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il y à de légitimes questions qui sont
posées c'est vrai qu'avec le re le
reflux de cette de cette épidémie est ce
que le pass vaccinale maintenant c'est
le meilleur moment est-ce que c'est pas
déjà déjà trop tard donc bon on peut pas
trancher est clairement d'une façon ou
d'une autre mais je crois qu'on a raison
de s'interroger comme le font certains
manifestants certains de manifestants
sur cette question est ce que ça peut
être un basculement dans une société
dans notre façon de vivre
le fait d'avoir un pass d'avoir ces
fameux qr code quand on a commencé à
commander un café est ce que c'est un
tournant aujourd'hui dans une société
mais vous savez moi je n'aime pas
beaucoup cette expression qui est tenu
par certains médecins qui consiste à
dire il va falloir s'habituer à vivre
avec le virus un étant entendu que l'eau
mikron serait une sorte de grippe bon
moi je pense qu'il faut pas s'habituer à
vivre avec le avec le virus voilà il
faut vraiment tourné la page merci
beaucoup michel fize pour votre édito
michel fize éditorialiste sur rt france
merci d'avoir merci à la semaine
prochaine à la semaine prochaine